and now it's time for bombing reviews
with Chester a bomb
tonight's review burn after reading
oh my god this is the greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life
here's this guy who finds a disc except
it belongs to another guy and there's a
woman who's with the guy the guy who
could be has the disc method guy who did
every disc and there's another woman
with the other guy the guy who did have
the disc but could be does not and
there's another guy sleeping with that
woman the woman who was currently with
the guy who currently had the other disc
no no the other disc a baguette no no
the woman who's really with the other
guy who currently does not have the disc
but the other guy in the other woman
have the disc greatly and I got you see
another woman the woman who's clearly
with the guy who has the disc and the
guy who doesn't have the disc because
they said to be two women and both those
women are going with those guys and on
top of that he's married so that's three
women the woman married to the guy the
woman married to the other guy and the
woman seeing the men who's currently
married to the other woman does that
make sense to you oh that one guy he
creates a chair it's like the automatic
woman pleasing chair if you're wondering
what it does I'll tell you
I wish I had a vagina full of monkeys
with this to me okay who currently has
the disc for the other kind currently
heads at this but now give the disc to
the other woman and she takes it to the
Russians and they're like oh please
please she's like one of the guys dies
don't worry I won't tell you which guy
well okay it's a guy who currently
headed dis from the other guy who
currently had the disks but give it to
the other woman the woman that was
married to the other guy no no wait she
wasn't married she was a woman going out
with the guy who was currently married
but never had the disc oh now it spoiled
the full movie everybody knows that
story so there's a CIA people and
they're like what's going on here and
the other guys like I don't know and
he's like it's all right Joe in the end
the fourth guy breaks into the other
guy's house oh wait a minute this guy
this is a woman who's another guy who
she calls me women who just killed the
other guy who just drove the other guys
just connect sorted that out things
might have gotten quite confusing so
again something happens but also nothing
happens squats nothing nada absolute
absence of things happened like the
Seinfeld of spy thrillers inmates no
sense but it was funny and he was shown
in a warm warm building so I give it two
thumbs up
I'm doing this because a bird and rope
aren't around anymore but I figure I can
take over the job as both critics would
you think of the movie Chester I loved
it me too Ray Ray Ray
indeed this is history bouncing change
you can change come on help a guy out
will you come on J come on what is he